[ Music ]
>> Since opening in 1985, "Les
Miserables" has become something
of an institution
here in the West End.
Not only is it the world's
longest running musical it's
been seen by more than 60
million people in 42 countries
and in 21 different languages.
>> If somebody had told
you that way back when,
would you have believed it?
>> I'd have laughed.
[laughter] Absolutely no way.
>> You say you knew
you were working
on something good though.
>> Yes. I absolutely -- I
loved it but there was no way
that anyone can imagine
something running this long.
It's crazy isn't it?
It's probably going to long --
it will probably outlive me.
[laughter]
>> I think it's one of the
great stories of the triumph
for the human spirit
and it's got --
because it's got
so many characters,
it's got so many ways in.
You know, you've got
the story of Valjean,
which advances the discovery
of virtue and the discovery
of faith, the discovery
of love for a child
and what it's like
to be a parent.
What it's like to let a
child go out into the world.
Then you've got the kind of more
teenage love triangle story.
The story of unrequited
love with Eponine, kids who,
you know, enjoyed Gavroche
and little Cosette's stories.
And any obsessive
policemen can enjoy Javert.
[music and glass breaking]
>> Jean Valjean's crime was
stealing a loaf of bread.
>> Help me please.
>> It was the beginning of
a lifelong confrontation.
>> "Les Mis" miraculously is
the longest running musical
in the world and it's -- I mean,
I'm as surprised as anybody.
You know, I mean, I, you know,
I always thought it was
a very terrific musical
but I never had any
thought that a show
of such serious note
would actually run as long
but it seems to touch
every generation everywhere
in the world.
I mean Victor Hugo's
story, you know,
is about contemporary
people, even though it's set
in another period setting.
And every country in the
world seems to react to it.
And of course Alain Boublil
and Claude-Michel's music,
Claude-Michel Schonberg's music.
I just -- is -- the songs
are absolutely fantastic
and they're timeless
and it speaks
to an audience of any age.
>> Let's not forget though
that Victor Hugo was already
an international celebrity
by the time he got to age 30.
He was known as the
prince of poets
and was shall we say massive
within the Romantic Movement.
More importantly, of course,
he was what you would;
I suppose assume today, just
a huge celebrity end of.
Who would have thought though
that so many years later his
name would still be synonymous
really with the world
of musical theater.
Not just really in his
home country or even indeed
in Britain but worldwide.
>> Take him up.
>> A dual of wills with the
fanatic police inspector Javert.
>> Continue.
[bell chiming]
>> The hope of escape was
his only reason for living.
>> Halt or I'll shoot.
[gunshot]
>> It is the decision
of the military tribunal
that five years be
added to your sentence.
>> You must have been asked
many times but can you
in any way put your
finger on what it is
that has made it the
longest running show ever?
>> Well I personally
think it's the story.
>> Victor Hugo's
masterpiece "Les Miserables."
>> You mustn't cry.
You must be very brave.
>> With all the power
and spectacle
of those turbulent years leading
to the French Revolution,
it is a story of incredible
courage and relentless pursuit.
>> Join us.
>> An exciting panorama
that captures the spirit
of a rebellious generation.
>> It's the most
interesting universal story
and it touches everybody.
I remember watching some
of the scenes that I wasn't
in way back before it went on,
you know, during rehearsals
and I was sobbing my heart
out and then I had --
I thought, oh my God, it's my
scene coming up next and I had
to pull myself together.
I mean this show -- well, it
makes men cry, put it that way.
[laughter]
>> It's a beautiful story.
I mean whether you're
into musicals or not,
it's one of the greatest
stories ever told.
[ Sounds of horses,
gunshots and crashing ]
>> The crowning point really
for Victor Hugo's masterpiece
"Les Miserables" really
started way back in June 1832.
He was sat in a park, relaxing,
heard a rather strange
noise at first.
Found out that it was
gunfire, which then led him
in to the June revolution, which
of course then formed the basis
of possibly his best
and most famous idea.
>> You join us today.
Together we will lay our hand on
the sword held of God and shout,
down with the war bonds,
down with the Monarchy.
>> It was the first
lesson I learned is
that it doesn't matter
how good the songs are.
If the book isn't really
strong and the songs don't grow
out of the book, you
don't have a good musical.
>> Victor's first full length
novel was one that we know
by a better title now, but when
it first came out, it was known
as "Notre-Dame de Paris",
which then in turn became,
of course more famous
as "The Hunchback
of Notre Dame" being remade
so many times, most famously
of course by Hollywood in the
late '30s with Charles Laughton.
But that really did open
many doors for Victor
and he became even
more celebrated
if that were possible.
Now just to put this in sort
of a bracket if you like,
Paris and France in particular
were already in the grip
of something rather
dramatic themselves.
There had been a massive
outbreak of cholera
where over 19,000
Parisians died.
Now some people thought
that this was really set
up by the government as
one of those mad theories,
you know because they were
trying to poison off for want
of a better word some of the
lesser desirable residents
of Parisian Society,
the underdogs.
And this of course then
fascinated Hugo himself giving
him even more spark to an
already dramatic story.
Now not many people will
know that Victor Hugo wrote
"Les Miserables" in
his long years of exile
in the Channel Islands and
to get inspiration for this,
he would write naked
at his desk every day.
Shocking some people who would
actually turn up to take tea
with him and things like that.
I think what is interesting
to note
as well he really didn't rush
this particular masterpiece.
He went through many,
many different rewrites
and for a while it sat around.
By himself, you know,
he changed plot.
Decided to pick it up,
go back to it again.
He was known as a perfectionist
and I think of course
like anybody who'd enjoy
huge success it would be
like today releasing
a Bond movie.
You know, everybody's
going to criticize.
Everybody's going to say whether
they like it or not and he was
under immense pressure
to make sure what he came
up with next was of course
an international smash
and of course when it first came
out that wasn't necessarily
the case.
Victor Hugo's "Les Miserables"
really was the most anticipated
publication in years.
And New York society
was a gag waiting
to know how it would be done.
And to give you just an
insight really as to how
that even back then
they were very clever.
They decided to mount
this massive PR campaign.
And so they would drop in little
teasers rather like what they do
with say like the "Harry
Potter" movie in today's decade.
So they just drop a
little bit in and they came
up with the first sort of take,
the second take and by the time
of course that the final volume
was released it was a momentum.
Everybody wanted a copy.
Everybody needed to be seen
with a copy of their book.
It was the coffee
table equivalent
of gold dust if you like.
And once again, of course, he
was looking at a mega smash hit.
>> Cameron Mackintosh was
sent a demo tape based
on Victor Hugo's novel
"Les Miserables."
The two French composers
Claude-Michel Schonberg
and Alain Boublil worked closely
with him developing the score.
>> We never go ahead with
anything unless all three
of us absolutely agree
on every step of the way.
>> I think that whole
da, da, da --
>> I can't do without
the first part.
>> Because you can't do
da, da, da, da, da, de, de.
>> It's like a safety
break that if two --
if two like something
and the other doesn't,
it means that actually we
haven't got the right solution
and we then carry on until
we find a third solution.
>> When Victor Hugo
passed away in May 1885,
he was considered
a national hero.
Over 2 million people
mourned at his funeral,
but this is the interesting
thing.
The theme of course throughout
"Les Miserables" is all
about social injustice
and he'd requested
that he wanted a
pauper's funeral.
Suddenly though for him,
that wish was not carried out
and he became, if possible, an
even bigger cultural literally
and of course celebrity icon.
>> When I first heard it
was called "Les Miserables",
I thought hum, I
thought, I don't know
if that name's going to work.
And so we called it "The Glums."
And now,
you know, "Les Miserables"
is the name
that everybody knows
worldwide and even
if you don't speak
French you know the name.
>> Since the publication of "Les
Miserables" there's been no less
than 48 operatic versions, but
the version really that we know
and love today actually
started out way back in 1980
as just a simple concept album.
>> Can you not actually get
that with a different --
slightly different rhythm
because that's got --
that's got the menace
that we're talking about.
>> I think a producer
shouldn't write for writers.
I don't think directors
should do that.
>> The writers and lyricists
of the wonderful concept
album were allegedly inspired
by another British phenomenon
that of Lionel Bart's "Oliver",
the record breaking musical.
Apparently they were sat
down watching it in a theater
and particularly taking
interest in the artful dodger
and as they were watching
Oliver unfold on stage,
they decided how
they could almost see
"Les Miserables" taking shape
in their own musical
opera themselves simply
by just watching "Oliver."
Now who would have thought
that a simple project
like Lionel Bart's "Oliver"
which also had its
own problems just like
"Les Miserables" would explode
from just an afternoon matinee.
>> We are there to compliment
the writer's imagination
and to bring -- bring that
writing to its best fruition.
What I'm very good at is
saying this bit's dull.
This song does not sort
of come to a proper climax
and I'm just fascinated about
how -- how the writing develops
and how that you take
a basically good story
and you make sure that the graph
of the motion throughout the
evening is hit exactly right.
>> Three months after the
concert album had topped the
charts in France,
someone decided
to take the rather risky venture
of taking it to the stage.
Once again the critics
were less than nice
about this particular
new musical but word
of mouth took off once again
making the three-month run
a sellout.
Of course by this point, other
people were taking notice,
not just in France,
but around the world.
>> That's the thing
that I always aim
for for my productions.
Once the audience settles down,
the first thing you've got
to do is in the first
five minutes is
to tell them the
language of the evening
that you're going to use.
>> Way back in 1980, the
first original concept album
of "Les Mis" was released.
It topped the charts without
really much promotion.
And three months
later they decided
to stage the very first
musical version based
on the concept album.
This just broke box
office records
with over a million plus people
wanting to see the production.
Then, of course, this was
brought to the attention
of who we know now to
be the super producer,
none other than our very
own Cameron Mackintosh
but it would take him quite some
time before he could turn it
into the British phenomenon
that we know and love
and take it around the world.
But when he first heard
the concept album,
he thought there could
be something in it.
Of course he had no idea just
that something would make
him very, very rich indeed.
>> Okay. One, two, three, whoa.
>> I knew from the beginning I
wanted to do the singing live
and I was so passionate
about it I wasn't willing
to make the film unless I could
do the singing live and this is
because I always find
singing to play back,
to lip sync to prerecorded
however it is done
to be an artifice.
At its worse, it
makes you embarrassed.
The best just forgive
it and in the light
of a comedic film it's
easier to forgive.
I wanted there to be no
barrier between the audience
and the experience
and those emotions.
[ Background noise ]
In terms of how it was made it
was a truly British production.
Internationalism was, you
know, really in the cards
because I wanted some
of the best people
in the world to do this.
That doesn't mean the British
are the best singers but,
you know, [inaudible]
>> I think what's personally
interesting to take note
of is the fact that when the
show launched in October 1985,
nobody really could have
foreseen just how big it was
going to be.
And you know the critics
as I say loathed it.
Rather cruel in fact.
Not really just about the
length of the musical,
you know the fact that
we're getting a free ticket
and the fact that they
had to sit and endure it
but they didn't really
understand even when it started
to take off and become a
huge box office phenomena.
They couldn't understand
why the public liked it.
>> The posh papers said
that we had trivialized one
of the greatest works
of western literature.
The tabloids agreed
between themselves
that we had perpetrated a
gloomy, dull, endless evening,
which wasn't what
musicals were about at all.
Musicals should be light and
frothy and frivolous evenings
and sent everybody away
happy and humming the tunes.
>> It took two years for
Cameron Mackintosh and his team
to make the English language
version of what we know
as "Les Miserables" today.
But in October 1985,
it opened at the less
than glamorous location off
West End in the Barbican.
>> Although his father
is Scottish,
Mackintosh himself was brought
up in the Home Counties.
His mother is Maltese
and his parents met
in ANSA during the war.
>> When he was young, he was
always standing on chairs,
with a stick in his hand
as if he had a great
orchestra in front.
And I thought he was going to be
sort of a bandmaster, bandleader
or something like that.
Then he started with
a puppet show.
>> I know a lot of
people do puppet shows
but they don't normally drive
the family entirely batty
all year.
>> The first thing
he used to tell us,
"If you're late,
you won't come in."
So we used to say,
"Well, we don't come
in you'll have no audience."
He'd said, "Never mind.
Every show you must be on time."
>> I just finished
playing a performance,
imaginary performance
of sadder days
and the stage door keeper came
to my dressing room and said,
"Excuse me sir, I'm sorry to
bother you, but there's a lady
at the stage door with a
little boy and she says
that he absolutely
insists upon seeing you.
So in you came, Cameron,
and was it your aunt
that was with you, I think?
>> It was my aunt, my
mother and my kilt.
>> [laughter] Yes.
I remember your kilt very well.
>> And Julian instead of sort
of patting me on the head
and giving me some candy floss
actually took me terribly
seriously and showed me
backstage of how the --
he mimed with mini the
magic piano from the pit
and how the flying
saucer worked.
It was attached to wires.
And I just remember sitting
on the stage or standing
on the stage looking
around and thinking yes,
I'd like to do this
when I grow up.
My nickname at school
was Darryl F. Mackintosh.
After Darryl F. Zanuck
who was having lots
of successful films then.
And again, I used to
start the first day
of the autumn term preparing
for the Christmas review.
If people booked in advance
they could get the tickets
for a shilling.
And if they got [laughter]
nearer the date,
they had to pay two shillings.
I was like a Hoover.
I sucked up any information
about the theater.
I got magazines from America.
From every newspaper
article I could
about anything about
the theater.
I was a walking encyclopedia at
school and drove everybody mad
who was much more interested
the football results.
>> When he left school
Cameron Mackintosh decided
to try the stage
management course
at the Central School
of Speech and Drama.
But he left after only a year to
get proper backstage experience
at the Theatre Royal Drury Lane.
In the mornings he also cleaned
the theatre to earn extra money.
>> I took great pride
cleaning that theatre.
The dresser at the
bar was my domain
and I'd very carefully
polish all the brass
and wash the glass.
>> So it must be rather
nice for you to be back
at Drury Lane in "Miss Saigon."
>> It's -- oh it's
like coming home.
I've always had -- that's
the one dream I've had is
to have a show on at Drury Lane.
>> He did have a variety of
jobs backstage including a spell
up in the flies hauling
scenery up and down.
>> As I undid the ropes,
they caught around my hand
and I was flown the
weight of this huge piece
of scenery took me
right up to the grid
and it stopped literally
six inches from the grid.
I would have -- only because it
was a very tall piece of scenery
that had landed on the stage
and they had to cut me down.
[laughter]
>> You know people
think it's pretty easy
to be an [inaudible].
Believe me it ain't.
It ain't easy at all.
>> Choreographers and
directors always argue.
The book writer tends to argue
with the composer and lyricist
and it's very important to have
a strong producer at the top
because in a sense
he is the one who has
to balance all the elements
and control all the elements.
>> I knew the moment I started
to talk to Cameron in detail
that there was a man
after my own heart.
He had just the same enthusiasm.
Just the same care that
he must be glamorous
and beautifully done.
That you don't save
pennies on the costume
or save pennies on the
scenery or something.
You do it properly.
You don't try and scrape
into a smaller orchestra.
>> I'm not a great
musician though I can tell
when the music's right or wrong.
I can overlap into his area
by sort of prodding him here
and there and thinking don't we
need something like that or is
that mood right or
whatever in his scoring.
>> Cameron is really much more
than old-fashioned producer
in the sense that he does
have strong creative views
and sometimes [laughter]
the team he works
with don't share them but
he has a very strong opinion
practically about everything.
In fact one of his qualities is
that you could be two minutes
into a song and he'll come up
and say, "I don't like that.
It doesn't work."
And then you go, "Cameron
just wait a minute.
Let's just get through to the
end and we'll work it out."
>> Well I can't help myself.
I mean, I'm one of these people
that just says what I feel
even if it isn't right.
I just have to get it out of my
system but I've got a sort of --
I sort of like sort of truffle
hound sort of smelling spots
in the show which aren't --
that I don't think are right
and I just keep on and on and
on until they just to shut me
up they'll go away or
at least think about it.
>> He had one complete
set of orchestrations made
and then he decided that
he didn't like them.
It wasn't right for the show.
He got rid of that orchestrator
and hired another orchestrator
who then did two more dummy
runs of orchestrations.
>> I had to scrap an
entire concept album,
which cost over 300,000-pounds,
which went down the Suwannee
but it was worth it in the end.
>> Have you ever seen a zebra
or giraffe in the jungle?
I mean they -- [laughter]
But I have last year
and I can tell you --
>> To a certain extent
now we live
in a world that's
divided into two.
Stephen Sondheim gets all the
critical acclaim and the shows
that Cameron Mackintosh
and Andrew Lloyd Webber do are
derived as tourist schlock.
Producers reign as kings of the
theatre coincide for the amount
of time that the public's taste.
Also happens to be the
producer's tastes and when
that changes then no matter
how successful you are,
you go out the window.
This has happened
to David Merrick.
to Harold Fielding,
which one day will happen
to Cameron Mackintosh too.
>> One thing when I started
off I was given a book
about Cochran called
Shaman Looks On.
It's an autobiography.
And one thing stuck
early on in my life.
It was his advice to
aspiring young producers.
He said never put a show
on for the audiences.
Always put it on for yourself
and do it as best that you can
and then maybe an audience
will come and see it.
And I think that's
pretty good advice.
>> It's not just a West End
phenomenon that continues
to be a box office
hit around the globe;
a staggering 56 million people
have now seen "Les Mis".
That's almost the equivalent
of every man, woman,
and child living
in this country.
>> Michael Ball sings with Lea
Salonga, but this is not a scene
from the hit show's "Phantom
of the Opera" or "Miss Saigon."
It's another hit both have shown
in separately "Les Miserables."
But everyone here's being
very jolly because it's
"Les Mis'" 10th birthday.
And hundreds of the cast
from its productions
around the world are giving
a gala concert on Sunday
but without props or costumes
and new cast members it
can get confusing which way
to go off stage but everything
should be smoothed out by Sunday
when thousands of adoring fans
descend on the Albert Hall.
>> The seal of making this
successful was the fact
that it won best musical at the
Lawrence Olivier Awards in 1985.
For them that suddenly
really had a bit of a clout
and suddenly people
decided to take notice.
They shot out of the Barbican
and into the West End,
where it has basically
remained for the last 25 years.
And when you think about it,
you know, it just goes to show
that even though, you know,
people would say oh no,
you know, the theme
is not really good
and it's not a warm
sort of topic.
Of course it's not.
Victor Hugo wanted to get
social injustice out there
and that's what he did.
But the songs are so memorable
and have been recorded
from everyone from the likes
of Dame Shirley Bassey right
through to some of our
most celebrated opera stars
including, of course
Luciano Pavarotti,
but I think what really
cemented it in the end was
that the public pushed
this through.
And as someone who attends
many sorts of opening nights
in the theaters, "Les
Mis" fans are nothing
like I've ever met before.
They're very loyal.
Some people, in fact, actually
book the same seats every
matinee and turn up week
after week after week.
They know the show backwards.
They know everything
about you know
when the lights should
come on, the scene changes,
if somebody's feeling
ill in the cast.
They become like friends and
one of the connecting factors
that I think Victor Hugo
would really love is the fact
that of course the cast then
connects with their fans,
their audience and then
actually brings some sort
of social connection.
I'd like to think it's something
he really would admire.
>> Well it started at the
Royal Shakespeare Company
and the first performance was
five hours long and so they had
to condense this amazing
story into three hours
and in fact they cut out
a lot of fantastic things.
There should be another
show, "Les Mis" the out cuts
or whatever you call
it [laughter]
So Royal Shakespeare Company,
we did it there for eight weeks
and we had no idea it was going
to transfer to the West End.
>> It's back to its
roots; the Barbican Theatre
where it started two and a half
decades ago to some bad reviews
and was just about to
go to the West End.
>> Of course we were all a
bit depressed having seen
such a fantastic
reception the night before
and so I thought I'll get rid
of all the bad news at once
and ring through the box office
and it took me several goes
and that was where
the story came from.
When they said how did you
get through, we've taken --
we've had 5000 calls it's
a record at the Barbican.
>> I knew it was going
to be a big hit years ago
but I didn't know it was
going to last 21 years.
It's fantastic.
>> It's overwhelming.
Absolutely overwhelming and I
don't necessary know that any
of us truly understand
the significance of it
and ultimately and
hopefully the impact.
>> It's actually
quite fantastic though
because the piece is really
about age and youth and to think
that I did it 21 years ago
when I was the youngest adult
and now people are
playing my role
that weren't even
born back then.
>> But it is really
interesting because of Nick --
>> Yeah.
>> -- to see so many
young people
who probably have never
a musical ever, you know,
coming in tonight being
completely enthralled.
I mean, you could hear a
pin drop through the story.
You know? And they just
reacted to the show and the fact
that he was incredibly good
in it as was Camilla you know
in their baptism fire tonight
but I was really very happy.
>> It is nice being
back on stage.
I was Gavroche when I was
in it last back in 2003
and about seven years later
I came back to play Marius.
It's been a dream of
mine for a long time
and to see it coming
true is an amazing thing.
>> Nick's done a couple of shows
on Broadway, I think he was
in "Beauty and the Beast" but
the first time I met Nick was
when he was the last Gavroche
which is the little kid
in "Les Miserables" on Broadway
when I closed the show the
first time after 18 years
and he did the last nine months
of the run and I was reminded
by his father at the
after show party.
I'd gone up to him and I'd
obviously had a few drinks
because I didn't remember
saying, you know, to Nick,
you know, you are really
terrific and I hope
when you're older you'll come
back to see us for Marius.
Well even though I didn't
remember it, he did and I'm
out of the blue, I mean I'd
heard that he was interested
in going to the theatre
so through another way I
actually approached him
and then I spoke to his
father and he said no,
this is something
they would really
like to try and make happen.
And then it's a great
credit to the family
that they have moved heaven
and earth to allow him to come
and be here and he's
having a great time.
>> You know, I actually
wasn't as nervous
as I thought I would be.
I don't think I was
nervous at all.
I think that I was really
comfortable and just happy to be
on that stage and really
trying to become the character.
>> Well what's interesting is
that he's actually got
a very mature voice
for somebody who's still 17.
And he's not quite 18 yet and
yet the voice sounds much
older than you'd expect.
And he's also got, I mean, a
tremendous focus all the way
through rehearsals and
when I first met him.
I mean he really, really
knows what to go after
and he just does it with
no problem, great ease
and the whole cast adore him.
>> The crowd was great tonight.
So incredible to be back
on the "Les Mis" stage.
Obviously a bit of a different
role this time but still
that same energy and
the same excitement.
>> Tickets for the concert sold
out in two and a half hours.
They'll have 17 different
versions
of the main character Valjean to
choose from and the comic relief
of Alan Armstrong
and Jenny Galloway.
>> How many thousands of people?
>> About 5.
>> About 5000 people.
And --
>> Are you nervous?
>> No.
>> No. No. Not at all.
>> I think once you see
all the people and know
that everybody's
rooting for you and know
that there is not a hostile
soul in the stalls or in --
anywhere it's just
going to be fun.
>> You know, here and there
I'm picking up the accent.
I sing with one now in the
show, which is kind of funny,
but it's very interesting
to be here and pick
up the lingo along the way
and make some new friends
as well, which has been great.
I'm really enjoying my stay.
>> They can come and see
the show here [laughter]
in the morning at 10:00.
They can go
to the matinee at the Queen's
and then the following day turn
up with the other thousands
and tens of thousands of people
at the O2 for that
extraordinary concert
that now has a cast of over 500.
>> Recently they've started
doing celebrity casting
in "Les Mis" in London and
we've been lucky enough
to see possibly some
of our better greats
that what I call the greats
that are going to come forward
in the next ten years.
The Lancashire tenor Alfie Boe
has undertaken, not just one
but three stints in "Les Mis"
and claims it's his
very favorite role.
>> I've done the "Les Mis" role.
I'm going to go back into
"Les Miserables" next --
this year in June to
do a six-month run.
But I'm wanting to really
break the genres a little bit,
you know, people
call it crossover.
People call it all
sorts of things,
but I want to just break
the genre and cross
over to a new audience
not the repertoire so much
or sing different repertoire
but make sure it's legitimate
for my voice, you know,
that I'm legitimate enough
to sing it, you know.
And still sing it in the same
quality and the same standard
that I would an operatic
aria in a way.
>> The comedian, Matt Luke as is
possibly better known for shows
like "Little Britain"
and "Come Fly with Me"
and he's actually begged the
producers Cameron Mackintosh's
company for a part
in the musical,
which of course did nothing
to dent the box office.
It shot it through the roof
and it was like a new injection
if you like of vitality
and once again, of course,
make it one of the biggest
take musicals of all time.
Cameron himself said
that well he's had many,
many hits he never thought that
he would be known as the man
who brought "Les Mis" to the
British and Broadway public
but how lucky we are
that he took that chance.
>> I mean I was very lucky
because they took me to Broadway
as well and every musical
performer wants to go
to Broadway so my
dream came true
when I was 21, which
was amazing.
And also my daughter Eliza also
played Cosette at some point
and I went back into the show
and I played the same
role Eponine with her.
So it's emotional for me.
It's like it's my whole life.
I mean, I think -- I have
to be honest, you know,
it's the best role I've
ever played and it did --
you know it gave
me an incredible --
well people still
know me today from it
and the album is still selling
that I made 21 years ago.
So, you know, I -- for
me it's in the heart.
It's really personal for me.
>> Now amongst many
of the awards that
"Les Miserables" has picked up,
this to me would be
the biggest compliment.
In 2004, her Majesty,
the Queen, asked the cast
and everyone connected
to the show
to stage a very special
version at Windsor Castle
for then President --
President Jacques Chirac.
Now can you imagine how nerve
racking that must be first
of all, but apparently the Queen
thought this was a great idea.
It was an official visit.
Lots of people were going to
be invited and apparently,
sadly there's no record.
There's no recording of
this particular night.
I think that this really
should have been recorded
and taped because, you know,
just to see our Queen
enjoying this musical
and she's already been we
can tell you, unofficially,
many times to see this.
It's one of her personal
favorites.
>> You don't expect to
win a Tony when you're
that age you've seen
it on the TV
and suddenly you're
told you're going to be
up for one and then you win it.
It's just bizarre.
I mean, I just thought
this is ridiculous.
I'm here with all these
stars that I've heard about.
You know, it's just amazing.
I used to sort of go oh no,
awards don't mean anything
but now, I look at it
and I'm quite proud.
[laughter]
>> Every year it picks
up more and more awards.
There was a special
10th anniversary show
at the Royal Albert Hall
and a recent BBC radio poll,
it was picked out as the
best musical of all time
and it's hard to imagine that,
you know, when he wrote it,
whether he would have thought
that his celebrity
would have carried on.
I think Victor Hugo would have
thought he wouldn't be known
in his time but his name is
now plastered across the world.
It's been seen in
over 30 countries.
It ran for over ten
years on Broadway.
You know, when you think about
it in those terms, you know,
it is something of a phenomenon.
>> And I'm just about to start
on the film where, where --
we're now working on -- somebody
is working on the screenplay
and I'm doing it with Working
Title, which is, you know,
the great British company that's
one of our best film company
and I'm really looking
forward to finally getting
"Les Miserables" out
on the big screen.
>> "Les Miserables", of course
is now a new smash hit mega
movie looking at all
sorts of gold dust,
from Baftas to Globes to Oscars.
But it's not the first time.
There are already ten
silent versions made
of this particular story.
There's been a radio version.
There's been a television
version
with Anthony Perkins no less,
which was kind of
warmly received.
[ Music, gunshots, screaming ]
It's one of those
stories that time
and time again people re-look
at and think they can retell
but nobody really could
have even predicted
or had the slightest hint that
the stage and Broadway version,
the West End [inaudible]
Broadway version would be
so phenomenal.
And of course, you know when
people said first of all
when it opened in London,
how can you possibly think
you're going to have a smash hit
with a title which is basically
all about being miserable,
"Les Miserables",
how wrong they were.
>> The film will actually use
the music, the wonderful music
from the show but tell the
story in cinematic terms.
I mean what we have here is a
wonderful theatrical version
but you know, the cinema we
will reinvent it yet again
to tell it for the cinema.
>> What was fantastic
on this was the chance
to reunite the original creative
team that created the musical.
So, you know, I wanted to
create a new song for the film
that talked to -- that
was inspired by the novel
which talks about the
extraordinary epiphany
of what Jean Valjean has when
he feels this incredible love
for this child that's
come into his life
and so I asked Claude-Michel
Schonberg and Alain Boublil
if they could come up with a
new song and I had Alain Boublil
and Herby Kretzmer the lyricist,
you know, writing a new piece
for me and that was incredibly
exciting to get to work
with the original
composer on the music.
>> I'm Poppie what a
pleasure to meet you.
>> What's your name?
>> Poppie.
>> Hi Poppie. How are you?
>> I mean the film
was truly beautiful.
I cried all the way through it.
I loved it very much.
Now what was your first
experience of "Les Mis"?
>> I saw it here in London but
I didn't see it until Cameron
and Tom were already making
the movie and they talked to me
about it and so I was on
my way to Italy actually
for a friend's wedding.
And so I stopped in to see it
and we had a couple
of meetings about it.
>> What was the biggest
challenge going into the parts?
>> Well I think the
challenges actually unfolded
as we went along, you know.
It wasn't quite clear how
challenging it was going to be
in the beginning because
it's very easy to say oh
and by the way you're
going to sing every take.
But then the actual reality of
doing that and the discipline
that has to come into your life
to keep yourself available every
day and your voice available
and Tom as the director
is greedy.
You know, he'll shoot and he'll
shoot and he'll shoot and,
you know, and every take
we did was the full length
of the song as well.
So yeah, I mean, you
know, ultimately though,
this was an incredibly
enjoyable experience.
>> I grew up with the -- my
mom performing in the show
in the first national tour.
She understudied Fantine.
It's actually one
of my first memories
of seeing the show is seeing
my mother play the part
that I play in the film.
>> I saw it when I was beginning
to think about making the film
and then I saw it
four or five times
and what was extraordinary is
that after the second time,
the melodies were just in
my head and that was it.
I mean, for the last year and
a half it's been going around
and around and around.
I mean they were
extraordinarily addictive.
>> Isabelle Alan.
[cheering]
>> A year ago she was
performing on stage at school.
>> She's just so gorgeous.
It was her first movie.
She has no idea how
brilliant she is.
She's just so natural.
>> It may be a lot for a
ten-year-old to take in,
but Isabelle looks set to
walk many more red carpets
in the future.
>> We did everything
in one take.
Tom, Tom left a few of
the songs the solos kind
of in one long continuous take.
Did very few cuts in it.
What he did was he
filmed most everything
from a multi-camera approach,
which meant that you could
do a whole take knowing
that the entire performance
was captured
because it would have been
very hard, I think especially
with the singing being live
to go from one take to another
like an hour can change
your voice, you know?
It's the time of
day, the barometer.
There's so many factors.
So Tom needed to be
able to capture all
of the performances live
in order to edit in a way
that wouldn't become
distracting.
>> I didn't want
to make the film
if I didn't have my Jean
Valjean and Hugh came in
and made me realize that
I could make this film.
I mean because I'm short
just this one person.
I mean who else could
sing at that level act
in such an extraordinary way.
He's a bona fided film star in
the old sense can carry a film.
Has a requisite strength to
play a famously strong man
but also has the grace and kind
of the spiritual gentleness
that the character needs.
It's Hugh Jackman.
>> Tom who at first day of
rehearsal said I need you --
actually before then he said
I need you unrecognizable.
He said if people recognize you,
I want them to think you're sick
in real life so I did my best.
>> He went on a really
hard-core journey to try
to physically capture
what it'd be
like to be a convict
of 20 years standing.
He lost 30-pounds of weight
and we shaved his head.
I mean we talk a lot about
shaving or cutting Annie's hair
but Hugh Jackman's hair
was shaved very brutally.
And then in the opening
scene, I mean this is
where he's kind of
quite eccentric.
He went on a 36-hour water fast,
which means no water
for 36 hours.
And then was willing to
stand up to his chest
in seawater putting a
massive [inaudible] on a rope
so that your skin kind of
went back against his cheeks.
You know, a lot of us
don't recognize him
in the opening scene.
I mean he's so kind of
broken looking by this thing.
I mean and then when
his character kind
of flourishes he then put on
weight and he changed again.
And I mean like his
commitment to this was total.
>> Yeah. My trainer on this
movie incredible guy David
Kingsbury has at one point
in his life was a bodybuilder
and he knew of this
water restriction thing
which is what bodybuilders do
before a show and you can lose
up to 10-pounds of body weight.
And right off the surface,
do not do this at home.
Trust me and so it
really sinks in your --
I was already quite skinny
but it makes it quite drastic.
Your eyes get sunken.
I look like hell basically
and trust me the headache
after about 20 hours is
something I don't want
to repeat.
>> I was up in Stratford
doing [inaudible]
and I received a phone call
from my agent telling me
that I would be playing the
[inaudible] hero Thenardier
singing master of the house.
[ Background noise ]
>> Just like all the singing,
all the tears were done live.
[laughter] They were
-- they weren't mine.
I mean I was definitely in
a fragile place that day
because my hair was
going to be gone.
But no I really did try to
kind of stay with Fantine
and Victor Hugo has this
wonderful passage in the book
where he talks about
Fantine really didn't want
to cut her hair and how
she receives a letter
from Thenardier saying that
Cosette doesn't have a skirt
for winter, she's
going to be cold.
And she sat there crumbling
the letter in her hand
for an entire day and then
just like around sunset goes
down to the wigmaker and says
take it -- how much for it?
He said 10 francs and
she says cut it off then.
And she sat there and trying
to be stoic thinking I'm
clothing my hair with --
I'm clothing my child
with my hair.
And I just kind of tried to
bring some of that grace into it
and not just have
it all be about me.
[laughter]
>> For me like any
physical transformation
that you undergo is obviously
going to be difficult
but I couldn't take it too
seriously because it was my idea
to lose my hair and
it was my idea to go
to the extreme physical
place that I did for this
and I did it for my job.
And a lot of people don't
have a choice about it.
A lot of people get sick
and they lose weight.
They get sick and they
have to lose their hair.
>> Tom Hooper who's not a
musical theatre director before
he went to see the show and
really fell in love with it
and he said how do I
recreate that feeling
that you get in the theatre?
And so he wanted to sing live
and what he does
actually he's enhanced the
theatrical experience.
For example, Anne Hathaway,
her song "I Dreamed a Dream",
which of course everybody feels
they know, is a single shot
without cutting for three
minutes of her in close up.
It's one of the great
performances ever given
and I think and you never cut
away from it so it's like being
in the theatre with
the best seat.
You couldn't even get that seat
in the theatre it's like sitting
in her lap and listening
to it, you know.
>> There wasn't anything about
this job that wasn't daunting.
I mean we were all just kind
of this mixture of anxiety
and gratitude and excitement and
nerves and -- but you know --
and then of course you show up
on set and you're just like --
because we've all been working
in our own lives on the music.
And you show up and
you hear Hugh Jackman,
and of course we
kind of all knew
that Hugh could sing
but not like this.
And then Eddie Redmayne with the
most gorgeous voice just coming
out of nowhere so I mean,
so it was exciting to work
with everybody to hear what
they were doing but I think,
you know, hearing how
talented everyone else was kind
of pushed us all on
-- me on at least.
>> So many auditions.
Six in total.
Three on tape, three in person.
Two flights to London.
[ Background noise ]
>> You know 60 million people
have seen it around the world.
London has taken it to their
hearts in the very beginning.
I wanted to protect what
it is people love about it
and somehow take that and
intensify it on the big screen
and I think it's how it makes
people feel and how people --
you go back to re-experience
these strong emotions.
I wanted to make the emotions
they feel even more intense
on the big screen.
>> I don't think I think about
it in terms of hard or easy.
It's just my job.
So you know, it's not like it
all kind of a feeling comes
to you in one great moment and
you're like, oh, I'm quite good
at this or oh, I'm
terrible at this.
You're so far removed from
it and at that point I'd done
so much preparation
that I was so into it,
it wasn't really
about performing.
It was more about just
honoring what I had learned
in the research that I
had done and just trying
to open myself wide enough
to let all that come out.
[ Background noise ]
>> Really amazing
to be up there.
It's so cool.
>> Well John Valjean,
for actors it's a bit
like a Hamlet or something.
It is a kind of role
you dream of playing
and also secretly
terrified of playing
because it requires
everything of you
and with John Valjean
emotionally, physically
and vocally everyday it requires
it usually all at the same time.
So it was an incredible
opportunity and I'm just
so lucky to have been
working with Tom Hooper
and all these great
actors, you know?
>> You know, I used to go to
the Empire Leicester Square
and the Odeon Leicester
Square as a kid and dream
of one day having a film
maybe in those cinemas.
I remember the ritual as I
left I'd always turn back
and watch the end credits roll
and make a kind of commitment
to myself to try to get a
film on one of those screens.
To have both screens at
the premier last night
with 3000 people was a kind
of great, I don't know,
homecoming for me as a Londoner
to have that opportunity.
>> You know he would have
everyone over when we were
in London and it was great.
He has a very, very great estate
over there and it was a lot
of fun and it was nice after
long weeks for everyone
to come together and do that
and he's just a great guy.
>> At the beginning, it's
a very embarrassing thing
to actually sing to people.
It's very exposing thing to
be like [inaudible] on the set
and so when you get -- you're
allowed to get so relaxed
around each other and learn to
-- and you didn't feel awkward.
>> There have been subsequently
some wild singing parties.
We were down in a pub in New
York the other day and Russell
and Russell's mate with a guitar
and we were all singing
-- singing songs.
It's -- I've never quite gotten
over the fear factor of it
but it is quite entertaining.
>> You know what?
I feel so proud to
be part of this.
It was so odd last night, we
had the premier and was ended
up driving back to -- there
was a party afterwards and sort
of drove through Leicester
Square and up [inaudible] past
where "Les Mis" is on.
And there in the Palace Theatre
where it used to play I have
so many memories as
a kid of walking up
and down there wanting to
maybe be an actor but never was
in my wildest dreams I'd get
to be a part of it so yeah.
I feel very privileged.
>> You dreamed a dream.
It came true.
[laughter]
>> Oh, that's so Jesus.
>> Yeah.
>> You may not have been the
first person to say that.
[laughter]
>> See Russell loves
a sing-along
and if you ever get
invited to his place
for a party Lucrezia right
after you do David Letterman
then make sure you take a song
because he gets everyone
singing.
But it was a great
way to let off steam.
I mean, we were all -- you
were not allowed to sing any
of your songs from your
repertoire in the musical.
That was the only rule.
>> It's -- you know it's easy
to see why Eponine loves Marius
when he looks like Eddie
Redmayne, you know.
But then equally it's easy
to see why he loves Cosette
when it's Amanda
Seyfried to be fair.
[laughter]
>> Yeah, no, there was a lot --
the thing about this film
because it's embarrassing
because we're all such
aggressive "Les Mis" fans.
It's the first film I've seen
when people would come in to set
on their days off to kind
of see how everyone's doing.
[laughter] No one
to miss out so yeah,
we were all very supportive.
>> Well, I think it's,
you know, when you --
I've always admired
Hugh Jackman.
I've always respected
his career and his work.
I think he's just got
fantastic range in what he does.
I just think the world
of him professionally and
so then, you know,
I was thinking,
well you know you meet someone
who's almost like an idol
and you think they're
never going
to amount to that expectation.
Well here's the thing
with Hugh Jackman,
he didn't match it,
he raised it.
I just didn't think
somebody could be so cool
with all the success
he's had to be this --
the most levelheaded person.
He is so calm on set.
He's like hi.
He's lovely and then
it's like action and this
like character busts out of
his soul and it's like wow.
And for me that's inspiring
at the beginning of my career
to meet somebody like that
who's got that perfect balance.
I look at -- you know, he's
inspiring to me definitely.
>> I spent the most time
with Eddie, I think. Yes.
>> And who did you bond with
the most, would you say?
>> I guess Eddie.
I guess I bonded -- no.
I don't know -- yeah.
I guess Eddie for the most part
I bonded with Eddie and Samantha
but we all kind of had -- I
mean we all had scenes together
and throughout rehearsal
we were able to kind of get
to know each other and bond
through like the terror
of singing live and
also the fact
that we were all major,
major "Les Mis" fans.
And the fact that we all worked,
like our ass off
to get the roles.
So but I guess I spent the most
time with Eddie and Samantha
and it was a nice little group.
>> I think it was
just the difference
in how you convey this emotion.
I think in the theatre you're
projecting to 2000 seats
and everything is heightened
because there's no point
having a little private moment
on stage you need people
to connect with that story
and to sort of feel what
your character's feeling
and on screen the camera's so
close to you that you feel,
you know, it's so intimate you
can be more truthful and that
that realism is amazing.
But then you can't beat
the live buzz of theatre
so what I feel is exciting
about this project certainly
from an acting point of view
is combining those two together
so it's kind of that utter
realism of film but with
that kind of live buzz
you get in theater.
It's combining the two to create
something that feels unique.
>> I had to sing.
Just had to sing.
I was completely, completely
out of my comfort zone
and you know very, very
insecure about my voice.
I definitely wish
I'd had more time
to prepare the soprano technique
but you know, I did my best
and I feel like, you know,
this is the kind of the --
it's a new unique experience
and the opportunity's not going
to come around very often so
I definitely think this is,
you know, the coolest
thing I've ever been in.
>> Well I didn't get a call.
That was the first step.
Basically I was performing
as Nancy in "Oliver" on stage
and Cameron Mackintosh,
the producer, walked on
and announced to a live
audience, yeah, that I was going
to be playing Eponine
-- that was my face.
Right there.
That was my reaction.
And it's on YouTube.
I've watched it since
because I can't remember it.
I just remember hearing Eponine.
I remember my heart nearly
falling out of my chest
and going -- because I've
never wanted anything more.
I never -- this has been
a part for four years.
It's a character I feel so
passionate about and oh gosh
and to get that news
in that way,
that was my reaction
right there.
You did a really good
impression of me.
>> It's like my inner,
you know teenager.
You grew up with Ali G
and all those things --
I was properly star struck
by Sasha and he arrived onset
at a point that he Helena
Bonham-Carter arrived at a point
which we'd being going through
this rigorous quite sort
of intense process forever
and they arrived in sort
of a lightness arrived
and it made me very happy.
It was just -- I
was a bit of a sort
of a lifetime aspiration
was to --
I never thought I'd get the
opportunity to work with him
but it was pretty
wonderful to do so.
>> I think I was excited about
there was a role I knew nothing
about at least I kind
of -- I knew this girl.
I knew this piece, I felt
so passionately about it
so to be -- that was the
one comforting thing,
I think about entering it.
I wanted to work with these
actors that I'd, you know,
admired for years, people
like Hugh Jackman, you know?
And Eddie Redmayne I knew
had been cast as Marius
and when I was auditioning
for Eponine there were posters
everywhere with "My Week
With Marilyn" and I was
like, remember being just
like positive thinking he
could be my Marius and working
with people like that,
that was such a highlight.
>> I was lucky enough to attend
many of these gala nights
of "Les Mis" and they've
always been magical.
You know, any musical
that celebrates a particular
milestone is always sort
of like one of those moments
where you think it's been going
so long can you really
inject something into that?
And it does have
that magical touch.
I think what's also
interesting is the fact
that as somebody who's seen it
as I say quite a few times now,
you go along and each time
there's always something
that you don't quite remember
from the first time
or the second time.
And you do come away it's what
they call one of those musicals;
it's what they call
a memorable musical.
Not just because of the story
but particularly with the songs.
You do go out and days later
you've got this fantastic melody
in your head and you're thinking
to yourself, what is that?
What is that?
Because a with a lot of songs
from musicals you don't always
know the title but you only have
to hear, you know, the sort
of words of "On My Own"
and it strikes a chord to
any generation and I do kind
of think that that's why it's
been covered by so many people.
So many people resonate with the
lyrics and the beautiful melody
of many of the songs from
the score of "Les Mis"
and I think it will
go on for many,
many years in people's minds.
[ Music ]